what is happening there reject nation
greg and john here today had no idea any
of this was coming out so you guys are
probably getting this bright and early
on friday morning we're shooting this
thursday evening yeah they unveiled
today the reveal trailer for spider-man
2 which i'm very excited about i play
both spider-man and spider-man mas
morales both wonderful games also a
wolverine video game on top of that so
yeah we're going to watch both right now
there are time stamps in the pinned
comment for some reason they're not
working our description boxes as of late
but they're in the ping comment if you
want to hop around also i want to shout
out my brother get jaby and achara for
uh giving us this lens it was my
birthday and he hooked us up with this
lens recently and i'm getting comments
about it so just wanted to make sure
shouting them out they do reactions as
well they're also covering plenty of
marvel content on top of that wonderful
videos he knows a lot about tech so he
was the right person to get the lens for
us thank you jaby you rock anywho let's
see what's in store excess or spider-man
2.
[Music]
for as long as i can remember
is that craving the hunter
the one who's talking
it's either him or the rhino
dude you place both miles and peter
come on
[Music]
nice
dang
oh damn holy [ __ ]
okay i know venom was like i don't know
if it was ever announced i know venom
was rumored for a long time uh to be
coming into this game but yeah it
sounded like craving the hunter or you
said maybe right now yeah based off the
accent yeah it sounds a little bit more
maybe a russian guy got the sippy maybe
perhaps a random russian guy but no it's
like he's he deals with multiple
villains obviously so yeah mean if that
is craving the hunter but for sure
that's venom and i love how that made
that abundantly clear but the second you
hear the growl the voice you're like oh
no that's that then yeah they show the
face oh hell yeah oh it's gonna be a
great game oh man it's gonna be a great
game
well this little teaser just had such
mood and tone and just foreboding energy
oh absolutely man and it's cool that you
know you got peter parker in the first
spider-man game casper my mouse morales
and i'm assuming since they're featuring
both of them in this game that you're
going to be able to
switch or i don't know about switch but
you know like eventually sometimes they
make you play as miles or something to
make you play as peter but the fact you
get to play is both of them
which i'm presuming is the case it is
awesome and that is that is so cool
that's exactly what i wanted them to do
for this follow-up where you could play
as both yeah we got to get venom in here
i mean i can't it can't just be the end
of the villains we had so many villains
of the first spider-man game i wonder
who else is going to be coming into the
fold in this one i know a long time ago
daredevil was even rumored to be in here
i haven't been following any details or
behind the scenes too much on this game
just sort of waiting for it to right
when it comes out i'm going to be
playing it so awesome oh that was great
oh i i got me so excited everything
you're so happy
yeah you got bet him in the game hell
yeah oh how can you not be excited about
that great year to be a spider-man fan
now we're gonna move on to the uh
marbles wolverine trailer
[Music]
go back at the get set go back on the
license plate
[Music]
there it is oh blood
yeah that's gonna go well
oh hell yeah
[Laughter]
oh dude and just the graphics alone on
the hands and the skin and the claws
coming out like oh it's so cool to get
both of these trailers because the
spider-man 2 game obviously like it gets
violent and it gets gritty but can't be
as gritty as you know wolverine like i
love the the mood that struck of just
like the messed up people in the bar and
then someone who's out there like all
right i'm gonna finally get the drop on
him and then you know just wolverine
after like messing all those people up
going back to the bar having himself a
drink
we're gonna forget it's gonna happen
yeah it's because you remember
the [ __ ] off yeah
one of those two
uh but yeah let me just pray is that in
canada i look like it was cancer is this
gonna be like an actual origin tale of
the guy it could be
and let me see here did it say quebec
actually it's funny the license plate is
hulk
hulk 181 which is no 181 november they
called versus wolverine oh yeah it
doesn't even matter if it's quebec yeah
better easter yeah here let me take a
photo yeah i have it right here
[Music]
[Laughter]
awesome oh that made me so happy these
are two like really great trailers
absolutely i mean and just so much mood
i love the detail here of like
you know just the realism of alcohol
spilling off the bar table here yeah
these really do feel like they're trying
to kind of give you both obviously the
game you want but then the like hard
gritty movie that marvel isn't actually
gonna make yeah
both these trailers
okay hell yeah all right man well those
are two great marvel game trailers right
there wrapped up into one which one are
you more excited for wolverine or
spider-man 2. i know it's uh for some
people sophie's choice some people an
easy choice
uh right now
because i haven't seen any game playable
i'm more curious about wolverine because
i haven't seen any gameplay for it
but
spider-man 2 i'm more excited about
because i'm very familiar with those
games and
freaking venom
all right guys leave your thoughts down
below subscribe click that bell hit that
like button can't wait for more trailers
to come out for both of these games best
bet we'll be covering them last but not
least let's do a pic
michael b
michael b i just got off the phone with
you so i wanted to shout you out i
wanted to tell you as someone who's been
up since a little bit before 5 a.m and
it is now 5 30 p.m and i've done nothing
but film and edit today i just want to
let you know
you need to start taking breaks all
right
like you were talking to me you only got
two hours of sleep in the past couple
days what is wrong with you don't you
know what unhealthy that is abuse
yourself stop overworking your body and
get some rest they say if you want to
become a millionaire don't talk to the
guy at the pub talk to a millionaire so
i'm here to tell you about rest
you need to get some rest
you're a good guy you dish out wonderful
reactions daily i love the content you
do and i love you more as a person but i
want you to kind of chill out a little
bit okay and also i hope you're doing
reactions to this stuff too while you're
at your full-time job on top of writing
a full-time youtube channel hope you're
slacking and giving 50
effort to both areas of your life that
way you can get a quantity done instead
of quality
[Music]